good morning Hank it's Tuesday and this
week on crash course we will be covering
no it's not crash course actually this
is a this is just me sitting in front of
a map this morning I awoke in my own bed
an act which I haven't done in two and a
half months in these two and a half
months I've been traveling around the
country meeting fans of my own channel
and even spending time with your brother
John and of course you're adorable
nephew Henry who's affinity for hammers
I will not soon forget well he's very
polite perfectly
I left my bed and proceeded to engage in
acts of dental hygiene while thinking
about thoughts from places then I walked
around my neighborhood to see what had
changed turns out not very much in fact
nothing had changed really ooh a new
grocery store I then went to my favorite
cafe and proceeded to resist temptation
of various carbohydrates or as I like to
call muffins morning cake participated
in gratuitous acts of capitalism
effective sat down with my favorite cup
of tea opened up my favorite plate of
ink with super sweet pen holder and then
I wrote some thoughts from places about
coming home and then creepily shot
footage of a stranger's dog wondering if
I was ready for that kind of
responsibility nope from there I walked
home carrying groceries from the new
grocery store I discovered and entered
my apartment to find that despite only
being home for a day I'd somehow managed
to fill my sink with dishes at artists
coffee mug from a fan a San Francisco
coffee mug excited to be here
Canada a Washington DC shot glass and a
cup that I bought myself that I just
thought was cool not to mention the fact
that I had all this post tore laundry I
needed to do coming home sucked feeling
entirely overwhelmed by the cleaning
situation I decided to lay on the couch
and fall into a crisis instead however I
still wanted to make the most of my day
so in true la fashion I got up to see my
therapist whose comedic approach to her
own profession often helped me deal with
the things that were on my mind
especially this from there I drove home
and tried to think of Los Angeles it's a
city I'd never been to before to try and
regain some interest look there are so
many different types of trees
none of them native to the climate of
this desert town and look this is a
thing that's made here maybe I really
should get a dog from there I drove to
my friend's house who actually owned a
dog to see if I wanted one and then I
remembered that the majority of dog
ownership was a lot like cleaning which
was the thing I was ultimately trying to
avoid with the addition of a lot more
saliva but then again again again dogs
are really pretty cute and when you
watch them it's easy to step outside
yourself and just enjoy a creature who's
simply so happy to be filled with energy
and to be alive and maybe that's how I
needed to be - more appreciative and
less contemplative not every journey
needs to be observed from the outside
sometimes it's best to sit in traffic
and stare and think does that guy really
love Holland Oats that much so returning
home again for the second time today
I looked around at my apartment and
thought man I'm really happy I put that
key ring there because I basically never
lose them anymore then I stepped down on
my back porch to watch as the palm trees
perforated the edge of the sky and the
day folded in on itself to become night
and I thought about how a sunset was a
lot like coming home in general and
though it seemingly stays the same we
mustn't take it for granted and I hoped
that that would be a thought poetic
enough to end the video so I stopped
recording because I didn't want to go
for four minutes like grace did and Hank
I'll see you on Friday